je ne saurais vous dire qu'il va gagner
mais tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que phoenix mais il a compris que
apparemment établissements aux
hétérosexuels en un peu plus de vitesse
donc il est remonté juin map mc loyer
l'autre violent et entraînait les tout
droit comme établissement vous êtes un
peu comme hier
voilà la deuxième il ya plus de vitesse
que la première low sur off est ce que
les images de l'autre extraordinaire
essentiel de faire du 15 décembre contre
les rendre un peu de vitesse il est
vraiment choquer border les voiles on a
pu voir tout allait aussi l'agneau et
orange on a dit on s'est débarrassé
d'une équipe et je pense qu'avec
l'équipe de lyon et aix en 10 ans le
taux
on a peut-être 60 kilomètres à bord ou
pousse toujours vous stabilisez l'avion
mais rester dans le cadre de pouvoir
commencer pour rattraper ce diable de le
féliciter de la en aux anses d'arlet
lancera lui tous les arlésiens qui nous
regardent et d'études des millénaires
les autres mes amis mais aussi le maire
et que voudrait de l'espace sud à savoir
une large et belle commune qui a trait
au lieu d'une étape et cette commune qui
avait d'ailleurs accueilli au supplice
de matinée avec une belle victoire de
vos points noirs
c'est big stack on est donc aux anses
d'arlet est seul au final jean on a
regardé derrière la young
il ya un petit grâce à lui que la pluie
un peu de vitesse il est là plagnol a pu
un peu de vitesse par rapport aux et
orange elle est en train de voir ce
qu'elle va faire le félix mérine
inscrits ont accompli le jeu il a fait
monter l'aïoli la mise en position
supérieure et la médaille l'a fait
redescendre il voit où il voit les deux
bouts et ils voient les globules rouges
de la ligne d'arrivée qui sont carrément
au milieu de l'écran on voit le bourg
désolé on voit la ligne d'arrivée notre
mix mairie ne fait que maintenant
contrôler les médias quand même si
ceux-ci de vitesse et faut pas qu'une
phase tout petit remonté laguiole dans
le vent de manière à ne pas la série est
là qu on vous regarde et vous regardez
mon sillage qu'il ya derrière
derrière la gauloise étrangers un petit
signal ça veut dire qu'elle a une
certaine vitesse mais il n'ya pas ses
filiales
lyon cherche encore ce week-end un peu
moins de vitesse mais elle a quand même
un petit avantage à peut-être écologique
avantage devant on dit couramment que ce
soit en voile moderne voile
traditionnelle bateau aux jambes et aux
mouvances et 7 phoenix mais il fait ce
faisant il met la venue aux étrangers ce
qu'on appelle son col des enfants
il le met derrière la yole de manière à
lui de l'élu vent négatif pour la
freiner leur honneur de vous avez vu le
petit outillage dont je vous parlais
mettre un but fr champ soit leur parti
est cruciale ça veut dire qu'elle a
repris de la vitesse c'est vraiment un
combat de titans parce que c'est commun
de nerfs ou savoir vous n'êtes pas fait
une bêtise là elle à la ligne d'arrivée
à quotidien elle va virer m la
championne ne peut que j'y vais parce
que le janvier veille elle va vivre et
elle varie va se retrouver sur l'autre
banc où allait prendre la ligne
d'arrivée la chose que vous étonneront
je vais faire sévir et les mettre en
vain essayé de rester au vent et l'eau
est du déjà avoir dit elle elle perd du
temps si les cils ailleurs le fait que
l'on arrive à repartir mais malaguti
mais voyait royal avit la ville et pour
se retrouver dans la même position
derrière mon avis les diables à d'ornano
elle est soit viré tout de suite soit
remontée au vent là l essentiel de
l'attaqué sous le vent ou voir comment
le battre et là c'est un combat vous je
vais peut-être combat de titans là on
donne de la godille mon ordi toujours
les sillages derrière c'était des
milliers de la vitesse du bateau la
rosette orange est appelée mobile ne
peut incriminer ceux qui ne sont pas
seuls hics minutes passent et envoyer
les équipiers sous le vent choqué un peu
la voile essayer de repartir
là on est vraiment dans une arrivée
finale suspense total à l'ordinaire avec
nos gens pensent que vous donner les
précisions vous expliquer qui peut
gagner parce que c'est la guerre entre
félix mendy
j'avais mal et je dis bien guerre
tactique est à la ligne d'arrivée en
tout le monde voit la ligne d'arrivée la
ligne d'arrivée à midi l'avion mes
chansons la voile blanche et le soudan
ce qu'il faut qu'elle fasse c'est
toujours resté comme ça à attendre au
dernier moment là tu as qu'il va
atteindre la taille de l'établissement
projet d'établissement vous êtes l'âme
et on va le voir virer sur l'éveil vous
regardez le laguiole ufr chanteur a pris
une petite après une petite rafale lier
vous êtes orange vif qu'est-ce que
phoenix miles a fait il va virer il va
bien il faut qu'il vive il faut qu'ils
viennent regarder fait semblant de vivre
et l'autre il va vivre et là ils
laissent monter il laisse monter il a
pris une ado nantes voilà il va agir et
pas toujours pour contrôler toujours
toujours toujours pour contrôler quand
ils vivent faut remettre la yole dans le
sens du vent donnait de la famille
remettre pour m e mètres l'arrière
remettre l'arrière là c'est pas bon il
faut que les équipes iront stabiliser
l'arrière-garde et laguiole est en train
d'essayer doit partir alors que rose et
orange mais je pense que phoenix mairie
n'a plus gagné parce qu'il est très les
proches de la ligne il faut pas qu'ils
laissent la yole laguiole deux boules
ailleurs il faut que la gueule et de la
fitzroy les deux viols sont à côté l'une
de l'autre elles vont vers des points
quasiment convergent ça se voit
nettement que l'établissement vous êtes
orange a plus de vitesse aval il est
parti je pense qu'à la plus de trois
fois ça allait trop faut choquer un peu
la voix donne un peu de la gaude ils
essaient l'ipad nous pouvions arriver à
l'extrémité parce que la ligne à deux
points il ya un point à l'extérieur à
droite de l'écran 1 point à gauche à
l'us open au boss est resté à se
plaindre pour prendre là elle va bien
c'est ben bella ou empêcher t'amusant
oiseaux
donc les 5000 de départ sont enlevées du
a peut-être cinq ou dix secondes moins
d'une minute sous la lune d'eyepet
chalco cet établissement vous êtes
orange la couche extraordinaire et une
affaire champions ils adorent pour
remporter sa victoire d'étape il adopte
donc une première victoire d'étape
alors l'histoire c'est la quarantième
victoire depuis le coup d'envoi
plutôt de martinique en 1985 et bien
qu'on comptabilise toutes les étapes est
bien avec cette victoire aux starlettes
c'est la troisième victoire d'étape dû
être champion vous êtes priés deuxième
reste tout de même leader au nombre des
victoires d'étape par commune avec 34
or la victoire d'étape ici aux scarlets
aux ufr chauffe l'eau du robinet qui
conserve donc 19 secondes mais précision
notre avis d'ici le brave ou établissent
par rosette orange des gens quel final
les téléspectateurs ont vécu un grand
moment avec cette guerre tactique entre
les deux grands patrons peu son félix
mérine à la tête de la pagaie du fph au
port et à côte chacun magee à la tête de
la part de l'établissement vous êtes au
hb oui aussi dans le soir dit n'y a pas
ce que tu dis cela il avait joué la
prudence chocolat avec une
je pose 60 m² et à mon avis parce que je
peux constater la voile rose et orange
est légèrement supérieur parce qu'on
voit que dans le petit temps lorsque je
ne voyais plus faibles et l'amérique à l
avance plus vite mais enfin quand on
fait du un écart de cinq minutes à 19
secondes s'il faut le faire je crois que
les gars sont gonflés demain je crois
qu'il aura du sport aubois et veaux
marins bon nos amis du marais nous ont
promis une belle régate que je crois
pierre pacaud